[Music]
hey guys in this video marina answers on
some of the questions most events are
eager to know who's chasing artists
starting the trailer and will John snow
finally ride a drag on the one named
after his father let's start with Arya
Stark your nyle singer is scared so the
sight of her sprinting to the coast of
NFL journalist knife in hand looking
absolutely terrified in the game tree on
season eight trailer has most fence
wondering what in the seven hells is
chasing her aurilla doesn't fear death
she'd stand and fight anyone or anything
Arya would not be afraid of White's or
White Walkers as she's actually fighting
those in the trailer she would not run
from them especially since she's holding
a knife made of dragonglass which kills
them my first thought seeing Arya like
this were either sensor brain or even
John died during the battle and Arya
sees it and it breaks her down but I
don't think it's the theater since I
cannot see any of them dying in 3rd
episode when this battle takes place so
will be scary enough to cause Arya to
turn around and run I think it's a dead
family member from The Cribs at the
night King reanimated HBA is obviously
reluctant to show us what's pursuing the
stark assassin as they blacked out
whatever's giving chase but fans have
managed to find a couple of frames that
show what could be after here's what
this shot looks like in the slide
inversion and if you look closely you
notice that she looks to be pursued by
something but a skeletal face in my
opinion that that have started to rise
from the Manor fell crypts are civilians
are sheltering judging by the scared
look of Arya I have the feeling that
she's running from something that came
from the inside of the crypts the dead
Starks I think the one chasing her or
least one among them is her brother akin
who died at the battle the bastard son
who's been buried in the crypts below
NFL or EEOC's undead Wiccan she cries
and is not able to fight him so she runs
that's the only logical answer it's
moment in the trailer with CR e of
fighting against white sand by walkers
that have surrounded her on the walls of
NFL so she would not run away from some
in the host of NFL and she certainly
would not run from any human but she
would definitely be terrified of her
recently deceased sibling rising and
chasing her and that's what's going on
in my opinion now there's also another
clip in this trailer
see Aria running but I time there
snowman behind her again Aria would not
run away from living man so what's going
on is that the two are not actually
chasing her but are running with her
this symbol in my opinion happened
before a white and the Rican chasing
Aria seen moving on to the next thing we
are going to discuss in this trailer is
John going to ride Vega so in the
trailer we see Danny Targaryen in John
snow walk up to the surviving dragons
gurgling regal and well nothing actually
happens it has fans wondering if this is
a seasonal finalist see John ride the
dragon in the fifth episode of the 70s
and one of the dragons legends no paedon
and now it's finally time for John to
ride one as well after Danny and Rogan
ambushed and destroyed combined lynnster
Tarly field army in the battle the gold
road then he returned to the dragon
stone riding shotgun
John watches as the land and remained
stoic even after John roars sensing
something in John history Aryan ancestry
joggin allows the king in the north to
get close enough to Patton
much to the surprise of Danny and now in
season eight with their heads down it
looks like the two are going to Mountain
Danny Jurgen and John regal do one named
after his father Rhaegar so John is most
likely going to ride ragel into battles
against Knight King in season eight
although probably later on in the season
has it been foreshadowed has there been
enough clues to hints throughout the
series that would foretold this event
definitely in-game gems dragons are
possessed only by House Targaryen and
since John is beside Danny the last
living Targaryen it only makes sense for
him to write the last living dragon
beside Roga since the end of season six
semi the first season seven promotion
photos I've been saying that this Dennis
outfit and pin on it foreshadow the
three had a general theory coming true
and both the John and the knight King
being the ones to ride remain two
dragons this was way before season 7
aired and before the night King rode
this area then his outfits for the
series were always used to either
symbolize or for share of something
profits used to mostly be a blue color
this is because Khal Drogo's khalasar
used the color blue to identify
themselves from other cars
Danny were blue a lot to remember him
this fact is important for you to
understand that the game with yourself
it's usually mean something and should
not be overlooked during the last season
Danvers outfits that contain Jagan
motifs and matches the color server
house which is pretty common among the
lords and ladies every Lord King
Queen wears an outfit that contains a
symbol of Kizer hers house sigil meaning
that there is nothing surprising the
Danny wears colors and motifs under
justice that matches with her own house
as you can see Danny often wears the
three-headed dragon pin which at first
doesn't hint not to mention confirm any
theory but on the other hand this same
pain that seems just like every other
regular pain might mean that the popular
tree hedging theory might come true in
the final season before I continue let
me just highlight this unlike most of
our TV shows Game of Thrones is a show
that has many times foreshadowed main
events for in advance let me give you a
few examples Ned Stark's death was
reserved in the very first episode of
the series as we all know Ned Stark
accompanied by John Robb Theon brain and
the few other men came upon at the
direwolf a few months later we found out
that this Tyrell was killed by stag
which actually foreshadowed Robert
Baratheon a stag getting Ned a both
killed by inviting him to King's Landing
while six pubs their lap behind upon the
d'Urbervilles that represents Ned six
children then he also had a little
finger foreshadowing timing Lannisters
death in the eighth episode of the
fourth season Littlefinger had a
conversation with Robin who was afraid
of leaving home following his mother's
death Robin thinks it's safer for him to
stay inside but Littlefinger told him
that people can die anywhere
Littlefinger said people died there
dinner tables people die in their beds
they die squatting over their chamber
pots and a few episodes later she was
killed on her bed and diving Lannister
was killed while squatting over his
chamber pots
these are just a couple of examples of
gamma transforming
just to point out that every small talk
every small item that we at the moment
sometimes don't even catch might be
foreshadowing something huge it is being
said and spin might be still nothing
more than a regular pin but taking into
account all the previous skins that were
shared major events that's a much more
diss on first sight regular pain might
have much bigger importance might be
occluded a three-headed dragon theory
will capture so yeah as I was saying
this three hydrogen pain beside being a
regular pain that represents Targaryen
schedule might also foreshadow that
beside day and night King riding dragons
there might be one more Dragon Rider
that will ride one remaining dragon Rago
let me reduce with a theory that this
three-headed dragon pain might be for
sharing so basically according to this
theory Rhaegar Targaryen statement in
the news vision the trio has
heads means that each of Danis three
dragons will have their own riders for
all of you not Cora but the books are
probably wondering when the dragger say
this I'll try to explain it to you then
he saw visions in the house of the
undying in both in the books and on the
show but her visions are quite different
in the books then is so no vision of Jo
going there son
but she did see many other visions of
which one was a vision of her brother
ager saying the Jo has three heads the
first dragon rider is obvious danny has
unbreakable bond and connection with
dragon who is named after her late
husband Khal Drogo and is the largest
one after the heartbreaking battle
beyond the wall the knocking rises Aryan
and Danny has only two dragons left
since she writes joconi to dolly feed
for John the other last living Targaryen
to write Wagle into the battle at some
point probably after he learns of issue
parentage two years ago already made a
video regarding this the three hydrogen
theory that already proved to be quite
accurate in that very also explains how
the three-headed dragon theory has been
foreshadowed as well as which characters
might make up the three hydrogen
prophecy long story short who those
three dragon riders might be then he
obviously has unbreakable bond with
dragon and Jon Snow being the lesser
garyun beside day and he would ride the
dragon named after his father Rhaegar
but not before the last season regarding
the third dragon rider that is required
to fulfill the three hydrogen theory I
said that it would be nice to see Danny
John in Tyrion riding the dragons into
the battle against the night king but I
also say it was kind of too obvious and
simple to be true this would also
fulfill Tyrion story of how he wanted
the dragon for his name day only to be
disappointed by loud letter from his
family
some claim Tyrion Lannister would write
Vissarion since he already managed
earned our trust and on shackleton
tyrion lanister claiming the dragons are
intelligent much more than most people
and will quickly recognize friend from
foe in my opinion is the best
explanation the only reason dragons did
not kill Tyrion journalist is a friend
and not an enemy meaning that even
though Tyrion did manage to earn their
trust he must like Lee will not be the
one to write the third dragon instead I
stated that the night king will be the
third ring writer and therefore we would
have Danny fired the ninth king guys and
just noise and fiery riding three
dragons the first part of my theory
already came true in the season 7 finale
living the last part yet to come true
just know riding regal after the season
six finale and huge revelation
John snowshoe parentage John is not a
bastard but rather son of Lee in a stark
and rhaegar targaryen also known as a
lodge dragon it's pretty easy to assume
that John is the second rider Johnston
will most likely ride regal the dragon
named after his father and this right
here could be John and Danny approaching
dragons to mount them
notice how Jorgensen reyga's heads are
down as if they are preparing for Danny
and John to mount and riding dragons
possess devastating power capable of
laying waste to armies and burning
entire cities to ashes but their most
efficient when they give their rider
Ragle is the only dragon that does not
have a rider and will probably change in
the final season just the other day a
Johnston versus night king was teased by
an actor who plays the night king and
have I actually see that fight going
down is with John being on regal and the
night king being on Masseria
the dragon fight is a must for the final
season and will most certainly witness
at least one okay guys there will be my
two guesses as a who is chasing Arya I
will John right regal feel free to share
your opinion or guesses in the comment
section down below
in my opinion it's definitely an undead
start chasing Arya and John will
definitely write a dragon named a tree
spider and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace